one of the youtubers do you guys enjoy
watching well i have a youtuber who
is up and coming i found him [ __ ]
like maybe when he had like less than
10k subs
but is this guy called john stone okay
okay and uh and he's a pokemon youtuber
okay
i like my pokemon but like unlike every
other pokemon youtuber out there he kind
of
takes pokemon challenges and kind of
goes
this is the guy way overboard is the guy
beat like the whole game with like uh
ditto or something or like no that's
pika spray
that's another guy who i also follow
yeah so so
john stone is this guy who does these
like absurd pokemon challenges and just
condenses them into like one video so
like a small ant right is a is a guy who
also does similar things he's a massive
twitch streamer but
right john stone kind of like he does
these like ridiculous challenges like
can i beat the entirety of pokemon fire
red with just one right right
and [ __ ] like that and like he not only
puts his own personality into it but
like kind of breaks down how to do it as
well so if people want to do it then
they can
um and i think it's only recently that
like you know we were talking about
people who make content which is like
very informational but then
try and put their own personality into
it i feel like he's a guy who's like
just starting to learn how to do that
yeah he's kind of growing off of it and
it's been really cool to like watch this
there's a few channels like that because
i watch uh this game champ
3000 i think i have written down here he
does like the beating like x game
without collecting a coin or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah and like i don't
know why he would do that because like
it sounds like pain
yeah small small ant does that too he i
recently watched him do
uh it's like can i be pokemon fire red
with only shinies
so what he would do is like he would and
he would do this all live on twitch and
then
make a video on youtube so like every
time like the starters would come up and
if none of them were shiny he just reset
the game
and he keeps going until the start was a
shock that's like that's like
speed runners like um yeah kind of uh
what's the word i'm looking for
dedication yeah or another one was like
can i beat all of pokemon emerald
without taking damage
oh my god and every time you took damage
you had to reset
i think i saw that i think i've seen
that one yeah that one sounds familiar
it went quite viral i think i think i've
seen a few like
videos like that where it's like no
damage dark souls runs yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah those are always like a
[ __ ] trip to watch
i mean i love watching those kinds of
content because i think i've just gotten
so
into like speed running and like people
who are just way too good at games for
their own good
yeah yeah yeah there's a fair amount of
speedrunning dedicated channels just
think that
not none of them are quite nearly the
level of obviously summoning soul yeah
everyone loves oh somebody saw
i feel like it's summoning soul and then
kind of everyone else and
not to be rude to everyone else but he's
just definitely like doing something
that's clearly appealing to everyone
nice
i feel like what he does so well is that
he just knows
kind of like how to present a story yeah
because it's like okay
like he's one of the few channels where
i'm like i don't really know his
personality right
but the stories that he picks to present
on his channel i like a banger every
time
because like if you don't have a
personality in your channel
then that puts pressure to make the
subject you are presenting
has that has to carry your video right
and it's normally easier to have a
nice interesting personality that people
want to come back to but if you're
someone like summoning soul to you for
some reason
knows how to present the most compelling
speed running stories
every [ __ ] time yeah um it's like
watching a movie right exactly yeah
his recent one with the perfect mario
64. yeah yeah
oh good so good i also really love his
um
which one was it the ninja gaiden one
yeah yeah the cowboy dude i love that
guy
and he's so nice and it made such a good
story it's so cool as well because like
i found so many cool speedrunners
because of his videos
yeah just because the way he kind of
sells them and also just kind of lays
out their entire journey
is just like i don't know i don't know
what it is right because it's like
truth be told he's not the most
charismatic or like you know interesting
presenter
but he just manages to write and present
and kind of
tell a story in a way that you just have
to watch because
it's it's like there's always the hook
so it almost follows like the structure
of a movie
you know what i mean there's the hook
there's the beginning the middle of the
end yeah and the end's always like a
really big climax that you're like wow
this
this this was worth sitting through like
45 minutes to an hour watching
just so i could have seen this climb i
could get invested into this story
i'm glad i sat through 45 minutes to
know that that cowboy dude got a sub 10
and ninja gaiden
i'm so glad his efforts got paid off man
that's so worth it
give everybody applause